welcome to a video that I have wanted to
make for a long time and that is where I
sit down and talk about my favorite
anime television show of all time after
I just had the privilege of seeing what
it looks like on blu-ray Cowboy Bebop
directed by Shinichiro Watanabe a one of
the best anime television shows ever
made is finally available on blu-ray
from Funimation and I have talked about
this show in the past but a lot of
people and rightly so have asked me for
a more in-depth video in which I talk
about my favorite episodes my favorite
moments some of the ways that inspired
me and some of the ways it's inspired
anime fans around the world and people
who are just fans of good entertainment
Cowboy Bebop is set in the year 2000 71
and it follows a group of bounty hunters
who are trying to survive they don't
always get along very well and each one
of them has a very difficult past and
the entire show explores that in depth
and in a beautiful way if any anime out
there is proof that good character means
that you've got a great show that's
Cowboy Bebop because every character in
this show is vastly interesting as a
person and the fact that I'm actually
referring to them as a person really
tells you how awesome these characters
are because they're drawings no but I
feel like they're people the lead
character is spike Spiegel who's voiced
by the great Steve Blum in the English
dub which by the way the English dub in
my opinion is superior and one of the
few dubs that almost universally is
viewed as superior the character of
spike Spiegel is an amalgamation of many
different people in classic film Clint
Eastwood for one Bruce Lee he practices
Bruce Lee's fighting style and you can
see it quite often in the show in the
first episode of the show asteroid blues
you see spike practicing that fighting
style but he's also a very lazy sleepy
guy who really likes to just lay around
and eat noodles but what's so good about
this character is his past and from
episode 1 before the opening credits
even air you see a little glimpse of
that past and you realize it's gonna add
a lot of weight to the show weight that
you're gonna carry if you haven't seen
the show you you won't get that but for
those of you who have he has this epic
depth filled past with this guy named
vicious the main antagonist of the show
in the polar
visit of spike and whenever these guys
clash it's just it's crying like I cry
it tears okay but since this review is
kind of special to me I'd like to tell
you a little bit about how I discovered
Cowboy Bebop it was the first ever anime
that was broadcast on Adult Swim back in
2001 it is still broadcast on Adult
Swim's Toonami today but I vividly
remember when Adult Swim was brand new
and it was just like the home movies
cartoon and things like that
I saw a promo for this thing called
Cowboy Bebop and I thought that looks
really awesome I'd like to watch that I
have this memory burned into my head I
was with my family at a friend's house
I knew cowboy bebop was at home
recording on the VCR yeah and I was like
I can't wait to get home and find out
what happens in Jupiter jazz part two
because it was like a to be continued
dark and I was just like oh my gosh what
happens it's a show that starts out and
you think this is just really fun really
well animated action cool characters but
by Episode five it's called Ballad of
fallen angels and it's the episode that
hooked me I remember just watching it
being like this this is more than
animation this is actually transcendent
of animation it just felt as if it had
something else about it the stylistic
quality of it and yoko kanno knows music
this woman is a genius to this day she
is probably my favorite composer I think
she is absolutely brilliant everything
she's done with Cowboy Bebop and the
things she's done since with anime like
kids on the slope and ghost in the
shell' stand alone complex this woman is
a genius of musical composition and her
score for Cowboy Bebop in my opinion is
the greatest soundtrack to anything in
television ever it's so well done and
it's the kind of music that reminds you
of classic jazz and Cowboy Bebop had a
huge impression on me in regards to
liking jazz as well and I'm not talking
about like going to a club and wearing
tight pants and going like this I'm
talking about like Miles Davis stuff
like the good stuff the good jazz that
makes you appreciate music as in heart
the kind of stuff that Vincent talks
about in collateral you know the
unpredictability of jazz
I love the score for the show it's one
of the best ever if you like that type
of music all I got to do is listen to
the opening theme called tank and you'll
love it now about those characters fav
Valentine is devastatingly sexy as an
anime character and I say devastating
because she's a cartoon so part of me is
like wow I'm a huge nerd and the other
part of me is like she's not real but
she's also really funny
a total badass like she doesn't need any
men to take care of her but once you do
really find out what's happening behind
that hard exterior of hers she becomes
one of the most heartfelt characters in
the whole show Spike's partner jet-black
is friggin awesome I mean this guy is
like the father figure of the entire
bebop crew he also has a very important
past and that's what I love about this
show all the characters are so fleshed
out to the point where you could really
watch them do anything and a lot of the
episodes are just them kind of hanging
out and talking and of course the little
girl named Edward that's right little
girl named Edward is just insane she's
crazy she's like the comedic aspect of
the show you know she's kind of a comic
relief but it's she's not an annoying
character like you could look at her and
think wow that character could be very
annoying she's this strange hacker kid
who just like says random stuff all the
time and you would think that would get
tiresome after a while but she's great
and the little dog lion is adorable and
for a long time I wanted a Welsh Corgi
it didn't happen though it regards two
favorite episodes in the show by far
Ballad of fallen angels episode 5 is
that one that hooked me and the one
where I went okay this is more than just
a fun anime show it's one of the
episodes that made me realize that anime
truly can be an art form that transcends
the fighting genre or the Sailor Moon
type stuff you know Cowboy Bebop was the
show that was sort of like what Metal
Gear Solid was for me and video games
when I played Metal Gear Solid I went
wow
games can really go beyond beep when I
watched Cowboy Bebop I realized that
anime could really go beyond
I do love me some Dragon Ball Z though
fan for life one of the most underrated
episodes I think of the entire show is
an episode called Toys in the Attic that
feels completely separated from the rest
of the show it's like a total standalone
episode it's very similar to the fly
episode of Breaking Bad you're like what
like where does this this episode just
comes out of left field the entire
episode is a tribute to the movie alien
some strange thing is loose on the ship
and it's giving everyone this virus and
Spike and everyone has to try to figure
out where it is
it's very suspenseful it's very creepy
and it's very artfully done and I love
that episode another great one is parola
foo which is this creepy clown guy who's
gone insane escaped a mental asylum and
is just wandering around killing
everyone and he can challenge spike in a
fight and it's awesome and of course no
spoilers but the last two episodes are
truly heart-wrenching there honestly is
not a single dull moment in the entire
26 episode run of Cowboy Bebop even the
worst episode which is probably boogie
woogie feng shui even that one I could
watch over and over again because the
characters the characters you care so
much about these guys there's so much
fun to watch they're so interesting and
they have so much depth to them you can
watch them do just about anything I
haven't even mentioned the brilliant
animation the animation is still to this
day some of the best it uses a very
little bit of digital computer enhanced
imagery the rest is hand-drawn and it's
better I mean I'm talking leaps and
bounds better than some of the animation
that's being produced today in America
and even in Japan because there's this
over alliance on computers now Cowboy
Bebop
is absolutely a treasure of animation
it's a masterpiece it's better than any
anime I've ever seen if you have not
seen Cowboy Bebop
I've probably overhyped it to the point
of insanity and you will not have the
same love that I have for it because it
taught me so much about anime it taught
me about music it taught me about film
noir in animation it taught me so many
things about art cowboy bebop of course
gets an A+
it is one of the best things in
animation that your eyes can see you've
been wonderful to me over the years I've
loved you very much but now we have the
blu-ray Thank You Funimation this is
available right now for a very good
price definitely check it out guys
also if you saw my anime review for you
Misha by Japanese ghost stories you know
that I am running a great promotion
right now with crunchyroll.com if you
guys go to crunchyroll.com slash Chris
Stockman you can get 30 days of this
anime streaming service for free they
have no ads you get things an hour after
it premieres in Japan there isn't
anything else like that in America this
is great for anime fans this is a site
built and run by anime fans to preserve
the quality of anime in America that is
just crazy awesome to me because I've
been a huge fan of anime for so long and
the fact you can watch all this in HD
with no ads and only an hour after it
airs in Japan is just like oh it's free
30-days just going to country roll calm
/ Chris Duckman and there's a ton of
amazing anime entertainment at your
fingertips my gift to you guys so guys
if you have never seen Cowboy Bebop I
strongly recommend picking up the
blu-ray it is one of my favorite
television shows ever made and in my
opinion one of the foremost examples of
how anime can truly be important guys
thank you so much as always for watching
I have a ton of videos to make my best
of the year my worst of the year still a
few more movie reviews to do all of this
is coming to you guys very soon thank
you as always for watching and if you
like this you can click right here and
get stuck min eyes